if you're the liberal bubble surrounded
by you know very very right-wing people
you kind of think of yourself as
special the transgender movement and its
ideology it's
anti-feminist and it's also
intellectually incoherent I've been
denounced more times than I can count
but I've never had anyone actually
engage my
argument hello I'm Julie bindle and this
is action men a series in which I have
interesting conversations with men that
actually get up off their backsides and
contribute to the work that feminists
are doing to prevent rape domestic
violence and challenge pornography and
the sex trade today I'm going to talk
with Robert Jensen Bob and I first met
Bob in 2006 at an anti-p pornography
conference organized by a mutual
feminist friend in Boston where Bob was
speaking about pornography its harms to
women and how men has an obligation to
recognize the sexual exploitation
inherent in pornography and to stop
consuming it now Bob if I may call you
Bob informal is always better absolutely
perfect well we're all friends we've
known each other for a long time but but
I do want to ask you this
question when you talk about radical
feminism for men is that not a bit like
turkeys for Thanksgiving I mean why why
would you put yourself out to embrace a
movement that is absolutely against your
freedom to abuse and exploit women it
seems crazy to
me um you know I was lucky to be exposed
to feminism decades ago in the late
1980s when um there was a real radical
feminism committed to a real conception
of Liberation and in that move movement
which I first encountered through the
feminist critique of
pornography uh I came to realize pretty
quickly that everything I had been told
about feminism up till then I was about
30 years old at the time was a
distortion or out and out Li because as
your question indicates feminism was
presented to men as a threat as
something that was going to take
something from us right and it was a lie
I believed like many men socialized in a
culture like the United States but then
I did something truly crazy I actually
read feminist work and talk to feminist
women and that of course changed
everything I also had a few very trusted
feem male feminist colleagues men
working in the feminist movement who
gave me a a kind of model for moving
forward and as I've been saying ever
since what I learned is that feminism
especially radical feminism is not a
threat to men it's a gift if we can
present to men uh an argument that it's
not only the right thing to do it's in
your own
self-interest to embrace a feminist
critique uh then I think we have a
fighting chance now of course there's a
lot of you know specifics that we have
to work out about how one does that but
in general terms that's what I realized
this was the way I could become a full
human being well tell me about your time
um as a professor journalist
so you're at Austin University and we
all know well we actually we probably
don't know how Texas has gone in
reputation and at least partly in
reality from being one of the most kind
of regressive uh state to what they see
themselves now it sees itself now as
Progressive which is wholly bad for
women because it means it's embraced the
whole sex work is work trans women are
women surrogacy is a human right but
during your career there what what did
you find in terms of the response from
your students about reporting on things
like sexual violence or what many would
call women's issues but we know are
pivotal to to to the the world that we
live in well in a way my feminist
activist career was very separate from
my teaching career I did teach in a
school of Journalism and so I did not
teach courses directly on the sex gender
question occasionally of course those
issues would come into my teaching U but
I primarily focused on a different set
of courses and I think that was
generally good people asked me do you
want to teach in women's studies and I
said no you know I don't have any
special expertise let the women teach
women studies courses I don't need to
take over that space u but my experience
was more in the the kind of political
world so I taught at the University of
Texas at Austin and Austin was the
liberal bubble within an otherwise
conservative State and you know whether
it's Seattle and Washington or you know
those kind of towns uh they they tend in
my experience to develop a kind of
smugness so if you're the liberal bubble
surrounded by you know very very
right-wing people you kind of think of
yourself as special and I bumped into
that immediately when I came to Austin
started meeting people in other left
movements you know anti- capitalist
anti-war and they would find out that I
uh was part of the feminist
anti-pornography movement and of course
in Liberal left circles you were
supposed to be Pro pornography because
pornography was Liberation you know the
story better than anyone yeah and so
that back in the in the 1990s there was
kind of an uneasy truce I could be part
of left movements and still retain a
radical feminist analysis of the sexual
exploitation Industries but over time
that became increasingly
untenable and for me the trip wire came
in 2014 when I wrote the first article
on the trans question that I had had
written and that basically got me
banished from the Austin left tell me
about the first time you were cancelled
and for what yeah so um as you know
there's been a femin radical feminist
critique of the ideology behind the
transgender movement since the
1970s I was fortunate once to meet Jan
Raymond who wrote the first really
book-length treatment of that um and it
was quite surprising because of course
the trans Advocates would always say
that Janice Raymond was this evil you
know woman and I met her had coffee with
her and her partner and it was a
delightful couple of hours you know
she's she's one of the best she's one of
the best feminist I know she's a
wonderful person and has dedicated her
whole life to research and activism
around these things so
uh I knew there was a trans question uh
but like a lot of people I stayed away
from it because I also knew it was
inevitably going to lead to conflict but
in
2014 uh some feminist friends basically
said why are you silent on this there's
women out there taking the hit for it
why are you not
articulating a radical feminist critique
of trans from a male perspective you did
it on porn you've done it on
prostitution why not here and I thought
well okay okay that's that's good um
somebody's holding me accountable I was
a tenur professor I didn't you know
there there wasn't much to lose nobody
was going to fire me I didn't fear
violence so I wrote an article that was
geared toward speaking to the left that
made what I thought was a very calm
deliberate argument for why uh the trans
ideology was in fact inconsistent not
only with feminism but with left
politics and that led to a FLIR of
discussions behind the scenes that I
didn't know were going on well before
you carry on Bob tell me yeah because I
think that people need to hear this what
your arguments were in that paper
exactly what did you say yeah well I
just pointed out um that the the
fundamental problem for the
left is that the left is supposed to be
focused on a structural systemic
systemic analysis you you don't fight
capitalism by simply fighting specific
capitalists you look at the system right
you don't fight American imperialism by
looking at a particular president who
took us to war you look at the system
well that's a I think an appropriate way
to understand human Affairs to look at
systems and structures of power but when
it comes to the trans issue the left
Embraces an individual medicalized
approach it says forget about the system
and structure of patriarchy we're going
to look at this as purely a
psychological question for individuals
that can be solved through the medical
establishment well that's a
fundamentally anti-left perspective it's
neoliberal isn't it yeah yeah and of
course leftists don't like being told
that they're in fact taking this very
kind of soft liberal or even neoliberal
approach and I think that's what angered
a lot of people you know I've been
trying
to to hone that argument in a way that I
could present to Ordinary People not
just in intellectual circles and in my
most recent writing the way I'm
summarizing it is the the transgender
movement and this is not an attack on
anyone who has gender dysphoria or is
struggling with identity but the
transgender movement in its ideology
it's
anti-feminist it's inconsistent with an
ecological worldview and it's also
intellectually
incoherent and what I mean by that is
not you know an insult it's that if you
actually read trans literature and try
to make sense of it I find it impossible
to do so there's no consistent
definition of what transgender is
there's no even attempt to understand
the ideology or the causes right the the
thing that I find most striking is at
this point the transgender movement says
we are normal there's nothing
pathological about being transgendered
but at the same time it
demands uh access to medical care
including medical care that that
interferes with normal human development
through puberty blockers for children um
right and so it's both entirely normal
yet a condition that needs medical
treatment well it can't be both that's
that's intellectually
incoherent uh and when you examine the
the work in the trans movement you look
at their writing none of it frankly
makes any sense and I don't say that
purely intellectually if you talk to
Ordinary People and ask them to explain
the trans movement most of them can't
because it doesn't make any sense to
them either right okay and yet and yet
for that for actually posing a challenge
to the left which we do all the time you
know I'm on the left we pose challenges
to each other constantly should we
support surrogacy is there such a thing
as altruism when it comes to the trade
in women's bodies all of those things we
challenge but we're not actually allowed
to challenge anyone on the left about
this issue
which has actually pushed some of my
dear you know colleagues or friends more
to the right which I'm very very sad
about what is it about the left that
means it's embraced pretty much all of
the core issues that face women today
and that are bad for our or or that
impede shall we just say our Liberation
what went
wrong well here I would just go back to
the the original radical feminist
insights of the 60s and' 70s which was
to say of all of these systems of
Oppression we look at in the
Contemporary World white supremacy
capitalism uh first world imperialism
and patriarchy if you look at them um
the oldest of those systems is
patriarchy it goes back not just
hundreds of years but thousands of years
and the the way patriarchy works is so
woven into the fabric of everyday life
right it's just so essential to the way
we are raised to see ourselves as people
that not surprisingly it's very hard to
to distance ourselves from it and break
with it and so radical feminism like any
Liberation movement is taking on a tough
chore when it says we are going to try
to to make sense of and then take apart
a system that provides power and
material gain for certain people that's
not easy in any case but I think gets
particularly hard for feminism because
of the way those patriarchal practices
including practices in family and
sexuality are so woven into everyday
life um you know let me let me digress
briefly but it'll illustrate this when I
was first learning about the feminist
anti-pornography movement and talking to
this friend of mine Jim Copan he said
and and I was said why are people so
angry at radical feminists for even
raising a critique of pornography
and he said well it's because it's not
just about movies and magazines that
gives you a sense of the time that's
when pornographic magazines were still a
big part of the market uh he said
because everybody knows when you
critique pornography you're not limiting
it to a critique of this one media
you're talking about the way we learn to
become sexual the way our pleasure is
experienced and he said when you come at
people and say listen the way you have
learned to to experience such sexual
pleasure needs to be rethought that
one's tough people don't say oh okay
great you know let me completely rethink
the way I'm a sexual being that you know
it's not surprising people don't um
don't immediately move to that position
well and it also ties into that old
cliche which is about if your principles
cost you nothing then they're not really
principles it's a set of convenient
circumstances and and the other thing
you know which may be impolite to point
out but although there are women in the
left there are female leaders in the
left the left is still primarily a male
formation in my political experience I
think more so than ever certainly in the
UK more so than ever yeah and so if the
political left defined primarily for me
in the US as anti- capitalist and
Anti-Imperialist is dominated by men who
have been socialized to experience
sexual pleasure through pornography and
more generally the subordination of
women
it's not surprising they reject that now
there's this a different question is why
has the left embraced the trans ideology
with such fervor recently and and here I
think there's still more work to be done
but my working hypothesis is reflects
exactly what you just said the left
knows it needs to be
feminist and one way to demonstrate that
you're feminist is to embrace the trans
ideology in the Contemporary political
landscape and as you said it cost men
nothing to embrace it it costs the less
nothing to embrace because the the
injuries that inevitably come from the
trans movement are suffered primarily by
women and so it's a kind of no cost way
to you know we use the term in the US to
Signal your virtue oh yes we use that
here too and so I think the left has has
attached itself to the trans movement
with such fervor because it presents the
appearance of being committed to women's
rights to feminism to the eradication of
patriarchy but actually doesn't do that
in fact in I mean it does it does the
the absolute polar opposite it it
threatens our rights and it also tells
us that we are
worthless and that we have no voice and
I say you know I I've said this
repeatedly if these men these bearded
man bun
dudes that virtue signal their way into
a faux
feminism
if they are so determined to convince
themselves and others that trans women
are women why do they listen to them
because they don't listen to they don't
listen to women why are they listening
to trans women so it's interesting that
the penis actually is the bit that's
listened to and that sounds reductionist
doesn't it because the last thing that
we are
um what's called radical feminism I just
call it feminism is we're not
biologically determinist at all we're
the opposite of that there are specific
issues relating to our biology that we
can't ignore and should not but that
this does not predetermine our status in
the world in relation to men which is
the LIE we've always been told and and
yet there are there are men that insist
that our Liberation will come from
embracing the
idea or fact as they would put it that
men can be women did they think about
how Bonkers that
sounds uh I don't think they give it
serious thought uh because as they if
they did I believe as you're suggesting
they'd come to a different conclusion
you know here's another way to think
about it perhaps in the United States
we're told that no one should be
colorblind that to be colorblind to
pretend that race doesn't matter
is to deny the racist history and
contemporary practices of the country
which I agree with we should be
colorblind in the sense we should try to
in our daily lives uh if we're white
treat people of color you know decently
not with prejudice and not with
stereotypes of course but you can't you
know sort of colorblind your way to a an
a non-racist world yet if you flip over
to the sex gender system that
essentially what the trans movement is
saying is you know there there is no
history there is no practice you can be
whoever you want and you know nobody
should say anything about it and it it's
another one of those places where it
doesn't make a lot of sense the parallel
is quite clear um and and you see this
in the way that when occasionally a
white person impersonates a black person
or a white person impersonates an
indigenous person there is an outcry on
the left for the the Sham as there
should be I don't think white people
should go around pretending to be black
so you mean like Rachel doil for example
right and there have been several notice
uh
well-known uh American academics who
claimed to have indigenous uh Heritage
who didn't okay that's all fine right we
should be honest about who we are
because after all to be a white person I
don't need to pretend to be black to
contribute to an anti-racist movement I
can contribute as a white person in fact
that's you know where I'm going to make
the most contribution by calling out
fellow white people well you know the
logic of that applies pretty easily I'm
not saying that race and and the sex
gender question are completely analogous
because they're obviously very different
but the minute somebody tries to make
that analogy hey you know we don't let
white people pretend to be black why are
we letting men pretend to be women there
was an outcry and people you know the
the denunciation cycle starts you asked
when I was first cancelled and I I was
trying to remember I've been denounced
so many times I've been shouted at I've
been protested I've had people try to
interfere with lectures I've given uh
I've been you know disinvited uh no
platformed as we say uh it's they're now
piling up at a a rate that you know I
only vaguely remember but the one that
really sticks in my mind and I think it
says something about the left is uh real
briefly there was a a radical bookstore
in Austin Texas still there actually um
nonprofit you know kind of anarchist
Collective and I had always supported
them you know given them money here and
there and done talks at the store and
without ever speaking to me about it the
staff had decided I was unacceptable
because of my writing on trans and
instead of doing what comrades do which
is you know talking it out they simply
sent an email blast to their entire
mailing list denouncing me and
announcing that they would separate from
me they would no longer sell my books
nor would I be welcome in the store and
I thought well this is interesting it's
not just that they disagree which of
course they have a right to and it's not
just that they want to separate from me
which they have a right to it's that
they did it without consultation without
the kind of you know both intellectually
politically U acceptable process of
talking things out and that told me
something about fear it told me
something about how the left wants to
impose this trans
ideology uh without actually engaging
the argument and and as I've said many
times I've been denounced more times
than I can count but I've never had
anyone actually engage my argument no
and say Here's here's why your article
or your book is wrong I think that says
a lot they don't I mean we were together
in Texas when my book on prostitution
came out and you know you you were great
during that trip we traveled together
didn't we to various venues to promote
the book and talk with people about the
ideas in the book and then one morning
we were due to go to a six form uh
college to I was going to do a talk
about the harms of prostitution and what
I discovered during my you know 5-year
research and I was told that I couldn't
come on campus because I was too
dangerous and my transphobia had been
mentioned as something that meant I was
an unsafe person and I wasn't even going
to talk to them about that but even if I
were I mean it was outrageous wasn't it
do you remember that I remember quite
well I got a call the night before from
a very distressed faculty member who had
essentially caved into this demand from
a small group of students and uh was
both angry at me for having putting him
put him in this position and apologetic
because he knew the whole thing was
crazy U and I do remember you know then
having to apologize to you but um of
course you know now that's that's just
one of many for you as well uh because
you're much more public you you you get
much more um intense push back and I
also like to make one other observation
you've actually been physically
threatened uh for all of the the
denunciations I put up with no one's
ever taken a swing at me and I've never
really felt at threatened and I think
that's an important distinction you know
in all of my work in feminism uh I've
never felt like somebody was going to
come after me physically or really try
to hurt me and of course women have
experienced that over and over again um
you know it's another thing that's
different for men and women in feminism
uh the consequences are are much
different which brings me to this
question do you think I'm a
manher you know um I remember believing
that cliche that you know there was
something about feminist women uh most
you know first of all they're all ugly
they can't get dates they hate men you
those three things are all true of
course you know we we can't get dates
with men we can't I've I've tried I
can't tell you how many times I've tried
but um again I had not only the
experience of reading feminist work but
of all of a sudden being around feminist
radical feminist
women and again this is one of those
very emotional things I felt loved I
felt cared for I felt like they saw me
in a way that most men would never see
me they saw me as a human being with
flaws socialized in some particular
ularly nasty ways but they you know when
I think about those women in Minneapolis
in the anti-p pornography movement whom
I met and many of whom are still
friends I think they saw me as a human
being they saw past the masculinity the
bravado the stupid jokes I might still
tell and I am forever indebted to them
so the idea that feminists hate men is
very strange to me now that's not to say
that that many women have had
experiences with men that make them very
wary of men which is hardly surprising
uh anyone who has been the victim of
domestic violence or has been raped or
has been terrorized by men should be
wary of men uh and so uh I think that
men often mistake the caution women
might um move forward with in in
engaging a man with hatred because of
course as men we're tough but we have
the weakest ego as you know we we
immediately need uh our egos to be
stroked we immediately need to be told
we are in fact you know big strong tough
attractive men and when women don't do
that I mean I'm sure you could write a
whole book on men's angry reactions when
you don't treat them the way they think
they should be treated well you know I
used to kind of I mean obviously there's
the the the challenge to that the the
way that we're ceed in particular ways
and one of those challenges that I'm
always really Keen to make is about the
manher thing but I just want to caveat
that with two things first of all I
reserve the right to hate individual men
and hate bystanders who let terrible
things happen to women and I think that
that's a proud tradition because if
we're not angry then we're not thinking
straight yeah but
secondly I
think it's really important to emphasize
what an optimistic movement feminism is
is because we don't think that you are
born bad we don't think that male babies
uh are somehow pre-programmed to hurt or
degrade or abuse girls and women we
don't think any of this is inevitable We
Believe utterly in Redemption although
we accept that some men have to be kept
away from women for their natural life
if they're particularly dangerous and
some of them unfortunately have been
given the license to be that dangerous
but we're full of hope we're full of
optimism
and and this is the the biggest
misunderstanding the the willful
misunderstanding of feminism that hurts
me the most and that I think acts as a
block for men to appreciate it and women
to take part in it is this notion that
we just think all men are shits you're
born that way you'll never change and we
just have to somehow contain you and
stay safe by being protected by other
men it's the antithesis of feminism
here's my last point and my last
question to you because I could talk to
you
forever
but how do
we get more men to see this we can write
books we can do talks most men are not
going to pick up a book of yours or mine
and they're not going to listen to our
talks and hopefully some of them I'm
sure will be watching this and I hope
they get a lot out of it or at least it
challenges their thinking is there a
quick and easy solution can we wave a
wand and get more men to just have a go
at thinking differently and looking at
feminism like it's not their enemy or
bad for
them well you know we can both point to
a variety of activist projects
and education projects that slowly do
that I was thinking many times through
this conversation of a friend uh also
older now who did batter intervention
groups so domestic violence perpetrator
programs right so men who beat their
female Partners were often
court-mandated to come to this program
and because he came at it with a radical
feminist
perspective um I have no doubt that over
the many years did those groups he
changed many men's perspective and
that's all to the good uh I've been a
teacher much of my adult life and I do
think that we shouldn't overestimate you
know how how education can change hearts
and minds but certainly I have former
students who I know were changed by that
but I keep the older I get perhaps the
more I think about what it means to
model feminism in everyday life even if
you don't ever use the term um so I I
mentioned my friend Jim coplan who was
25 years older than me and if not but
for his example uh I have no idea where
I'd be today it wasn't just that he
lectured me on radical feminism I
watched the way he lived and he lived
those principles in a very deep and
moving way and so I also think you know
whether we are politically active or not
as men whether we Embrace feminism
publicly or not there is a way to do
that and as you pointed out the
alternative is to be a bystander who
doesn't intervene so the way we talk to
not only our own boy children or you
know Boys in our
lives but the way we walk through the
world matters a lot when questions about
pornography come up are we willing to
forthrightly say oh no I don't use it
and I I think it's you know a woman
hating practice and here's why
uh all of these things are part of the
slow process of what we hope creates a
more civilized World um there's no
guarantee um you know the same process
is going forward on race in the United
States with progress and defeat and you
know back and forth um I I certainly I
don't have any new strategies I
certainly don't have a crystal ball I
know that the the the way that I've
tried to live has not only I hope
contributed to a movement but it's made
me a better person it's allowed me to
live a deeper and richer emotional life
it's improved my relationships not just
with women but with other men um and so
you
know you roll the dice and hope for the
best but I think there is politics there
is education and then there is everyday
life and they're all part of the the
project and I I you know I hope when I
die people think well I made some
contribution but if nothing else I know
you know my own life was improved by
being willing to think about the way
that the short-term material benefits of
being a man in patriarchy were not worth
giving up some of your own humanity and
in the end that's that's what I tell men
is if you want to be human you C you can
be a real man or you can be a human
being but you can't be both I love that
I love that you can be fully human or
you can be a real man is the replacement
t-shirt for this is what a feminist
looks like and Bob I could talk to you
all day but we are going to have to
finish here and that's a brilliant
brilliant note to end
[Applause]
on
[Music]